the true fans that we're not here for a
long time to say hello or just get a
sight I'm not thrilled about and you
know I'm so excited to bring this movie
I'm so excited to be in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but to bring this
particular character to life what a joy
and it's going to be really exciting not
least because I haven't seen the film
yet either so I'm sitting in the world
premiere with other people watching it
for the first time and it's my first
time so so I'm stoked
yeah he's definitely a superhero I mean
whatever whatever whatever the
difference is art which I'm very happy
about these is a superhero and I'm I
don't know I'm just yeah I'm ready I'm
ready to help Marvel with that new left
turn that third chapter and this is
really going to open up the cinematic
universe to other dimensions literally
and so the canvas is going to get a
whole lot bigger for these incredible
characters and I can't wait to join them
and have some fun playing with them as
well it's been extraordinary we started
our tour off in the beautiful Hong Kong
which is almost a character in this film
but plays such an integral part it's a
massive feature in the film which I'm a
giveaway but it's very cool and boy did
they give us a welcome and it was unlike
had I think I've experienced and the
energy the love just the complete kind
of yeah noble sort of positivism about
the whole thing very very excited to see
it and yeah and then we went out to
Shanghai and it was equally crazy and
wonderful and yeah it was a beautiful
experience both places offered us
wonderful experiences with food and
culture and inviting us to enjoy a
little bit of what they had to offer in
the brief time we were there talking
about the film so you know really good
memories yeah there's something for
everyone here it's got a great cast of
many nationalities and it is a story
that is what embraces a huge body of the
world and also at the same time it's
it's about a reality that we all share
there's a sort of common universal human
sort of strength to the story but also
to the purpose of this character coming
into our lives so yeah I think it will
resonate with a lot of people and I just
think you know people crave something
new and different and I think the
visuals and the trip of this film just
the excitement viscerally of what it's
going to be like watching it's going to
be something for everyone really we are
headed to London and then after that
we're going to Berlin and then we
these coasts to go to New York which is
his kind of spiritual and geographical
home as a character so be really nice to
end it all that we have something new
for everybody and we're so excited yeah
it's I don't know it's it's everything
you expect from more Marvel and more
it's like super grown-up but it's all
about the multiverse so we're going
through portals into new new worlds and
experiences it's going to blow
everybody's minds I think it's gonna
bring in people who wouldn't necessarily
have been to a Marvel film before
because it's about humans and it's not
actually about a superhero it's about a
sorcerer who learns magic and an AI
player the sorcerer supreme who teaches
magic to humans and it's a kind of magic
that we can all learn to be honest dr.
strange is particularly good at it so he
kind of has special powers but she's
teaching him and everyone she's teaching
about mindfulness about you know having
a quiet mind and being in control of
oneself and and serving things greater
than yourself and looking beyond ego and
fear which is the kind of time anything
to think about it's really fresh that's
what I loved so much about it it's it's
kind of unexpected we're dealing with
magic and the occult and a different
kind of fantasy and and I think Scott
had a really really fresh take on it you
know he was so interested in the idea of
building up rather than tearing down and
both emotionally and with the you know
just physically with the buildings and
that sort of thing so yeah I was excited
to take a new journey like that it is
definitely a global film I mean it goes
beyond just planet Earth
so it's for it's for all beings really
yeah it's it's it's very and I think
it's very relatable to all people a lot
of the themes about you know mindfulness
which i think is really very on point
topic that we've sort of come back
around to
since the time when they wrote the comic
books so yeah I think it's got a little
bit for everything and it's really
grown-up and yet it's really fun at the
same time so it's for all ages yeah I'm
a neophyte in the cinematic Marvel
Universe I was I was a Marvel fan as a
kid mainly the you know the major heroes
like spider-man Iron Man daredevil a
little bit so Doctor Strange is is
fairly new to me I'm somewhat aware of
his origins but in terms of experience
like this brand new for me this whole
process for me to the level that I was
involved in it was shrouded deeply in
mystery and so I like most people here
have not seen it truly excited to to
witness the the artistry of so many
people that have come together to create
this film tonight I'm here with my wife
so it's kind of a special date so yeah
I'm excited you know what I'm interested
in with this film is that yes it's going
to have amazing special effects and
fantastic acting it's going to be visual
eye candy of course but one thing I
loved about this particular film was
it's kind of deeper probing of the of
the existential questions that we all
face what is our worth what is our value
when how we perceive ourselves is
destroyed and we have to start anew
where do we begin
what journey what spiritual journeys
does that send us on that's a
fascinating thing to ponder I think all
of us kind of have a crossroads moment
like that in our lives
if we're lucky anyway and so when we
follow Doctor Strange on his particular
journey and a spiritual one no less it's
probably not like one we'd experience in
our own lives but no that's fun to watch
certainly well it's my first Marvel
premiere and yeah it's incredible to me
and just I mean it just kind of sort of
mirrors the sort of magnitude of the
production values as well and
yes really exciting though yeah I'm
really thrilled to be here this I think
is a real sort of journey of you know
this arrogant neurosurgeon who as a
tragic Russian as lose his ability to
heal and it's this broken man that goes
and finds himself but yet stumbles that
he has this ability for the mystic arts
well yeah it kind of encompasses all the
world and then I think that the it's
it's the gateway into this multiverse
where we end off darker forces it's fun
when you get to you know shut up
Hollywood Boulevard it makes you feel
you're part of a big film and all the
fans are here on the Marvel fans is
dedicated is it the universe obviously
are knew about when I read the comics
and I watch the film but that the fans
will be so intense it is part of that
universe but it has a slightly different
touch she said it's not a man with
superpowers it's people with inner
strength and as such was written in the
sixties everything was about that and
those inner strength that he eventually
finds are tremendously strong he will
definitely be up there with the best I
was a big Doctor Strange fan as a kid I
remember finding one of these comics and
I used to go to these yard sales and
flea markets with my mom and you know
you would always find all those comics
and old things so in one of the bunches
that I would grab was this Doctor
Strange he was like what is this I never
heard of it
and I loved it and I loved him so when I
heard about this film I was like I I
really want to do this
because I just like the character was so
different from all of the other
characters in that universe and it just
felt like in a world where like so many
things that you know so much about
already are being made this was a thing
where it's like nobody knows who this
guy is I love that one I want to work on
the thing that nobody knows where he is
it was just fun and benedict's great
it's just a great opportunity or
something weird scotch great we had a
blast together Scott is wonderful he's
really smart he knows so much about
filmmaking so much about films you know
and I'm a real film keep myself but I
sort of met my match when I was talking
to him about things because he is deep
into it and it was in his love for this
character particularly was so bad the
first time I met him I was like I was
just so happy that he knew the character
as well as he did you know and and he's
just been a joy to work with really fun
fun we had a blast
I mean it's surreal you know we just
finished the movie I mean I this will be
the first time I've watched the 3d print
all the way through with sound I was
working on it until the last second but
I got I did get finished and it's at the
TCL Chinese Theatre the most famous
theater in the world so it's it's
awesome it's really fantastic it's very
different
you know the Doctor Strange comic when
it came along in the 60s was a complete
breath of fresh air in the Marvel comic
book universe and in the same way we
tried to make the movie a breath of
fresh air and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so just like the comic hit in
the 60s we're bringing a lot of
weirdness other dimensions magic just a
lot of things that kind of break open
the mold of what a Marvel movie could be
it was crazy
first of all being with Benedict
Cumberbatch in Asia Asia is like
with Elvis you know I mean it was a lot
of screaming girls but it was it was
fantastic they're real Marvel fans over
there and they really were excited and I
think very appreciated that we were
there and where the movies opening in in
China which is a privilege and an honor
and it's awesome we've made 14 now of
our films within our Cinematic Universe
and it did feel like it was time to take
a turn to do something a little
different to go into other dimensions
and the multiverse as we call it and
Doctor Strange was right there in the
early 60s family who just walked by
co-created him with Steve Ditko an
amazing artist and he was sort of there
amongst the Avengers for so long for
decades and we felt finally it was time
to introduce him to the world
take audiences on a very wild ride with
him and then now we've established him
in the universe and we'll see him going
forward in the other in the next films
we met first time with Scott Derrickson
almost two years ago know what am I
saying even longer that three or four
years ago and he really came in with a
vision about taking these Steve Ditko
panels from the comics now 50-year 4550
years old
and saying these are still progressive
images these are still mind-bending
images how could we bring them to life
on the big screen and that's what he's
now just completed after years and years
working with our visual effects
supervisor steps already Industrial
Light and Magic some of the best visual
effect vendors around and bring it to
life and I'm really excited for
audiences to finally see what we have in
store I think the story of this of
Doctor Strange and the journey goes on
is totally Universal it's something that
we can apply it to all our lives
like all great Marvel characters it's a
story that translates across cultures
across walks of life and there's a real
message I think at the core of this
movie that when we've shown the movie
too early audiences as we're as we're
shaping the movie in editorial they've
really responded to they say they like
the effects they say they like the
action they say they like all those
things that you get when you have a
Marvel movie but they've also said I
like the philosophy of this movie and I
like what you can learn from it what the
takeaways are what the morale is and
that's universal that has worldwide
appeal from our earliest meetings with
Scott Derrickson he came in and threw
the gauntlet down and said we have to do
things that no one has ever seen before
we have to push the limits of what an
action scene can be of what a Marvel
movie
can be what a movie about magic can be
and we sort of pointed to a place on
horizon and said we want to do something
like that
and we weren't quite sure how we were
going to get there we had to build a lot
of vehicles and cross a lot of miles and
go the wrong way and come back the wrong
way the right way to figure out exactly
how to achieve some of these incredibly
complex and unique action sequences and
visual dynamism in the film and that was
absolutely under Scott's leadership and
and Scott Scott Colin and Colin is hit
and saying we're going there we're doing
this
you